pressing my rich dad said to me if
you're going to be a rich man you better
learn two things right now be an
entrepreneur you've got to learn how to
sell and secondly got to know real
estate because real estate is debt and
taxes what do you mean debt and taxes so
in 1974 I took my first real estate
course and
opened my eyes up because you don't need
money to buy real estate and you pay no
taxes on top of it so just before I get
out of the Marine Corps you know I get a
job with Xerox learn how to sell so I
got sales and then I understood real
estate so why am I rich man today
because I took two courses learned how
to sell and learn about real estate and
my poor dad the pH thesis go back to
school get your MB and get your PhD I'm
going then I'd wind up like you a poor
Highly Educated man with a 401k